es ist keine Hochburg aber die Wiege der
AFD gegründet vorbei zehn Jahren in
Oberursel Hessen seitdem in Flügel
kämpfen stetig radikalisiert und zuletzt
in der Energiekrise widerstätig
gestiegen eine Spurensuche die hier in
der Fußgängerzone beginnt
nur die AFD ist hier ja die anderen
kommen nur wenn es dann mit einer Woche
oder zwei Wochen wenn dann am Sonntag
die Entscheidung ist und sonst ist nur
die afd-press der AFD ja offensichtlich
gibt es Antworten oder finden manche
Leute antworten genau in dieser Partei
was ich hochproblematisch finde ich
glaube da müssen sich ja die anderen
Parteien ein bisschen überlegen wie
sowas passieren kann diese Politik die
hier gefahren wird momentan von den
etablierten Parteien eine Katastrophe
finde ich ja weil sie abgehoben sind
weil sie kein Bezug mehr haben das denke
ich Versagen allgemein ja davon
profitiert die AFD
bundesweit geht der Trend für die AFD
nach oben Umfragen im Durchschnitt sehen
die extrem rechte Partei bei knapp 15
Prozent auch in westländern wie
Rheinland-Pfalz und Hessen deutlich
zweistellig in den Flächenländern im
Osten überall weit über 20 Prozent plus
7,3 zuletzt in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in
Sachsen oder Thüringen kratzt die AFD
gar an der 30% Marke die Länder Chefs
Alarm versuchen irgendwie den Unmut
einzudämmen die Strategie des Erstarken
der AFD zu stoppen ist eine kluge
Realpolitik zu machen den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern hilft am meisten wenn es nur
konkrete Lösung gibt die Sie in Ihrem
Unternehmen in ihrem Portemonnaie und zu
Hause in der Familie spüren also die
wichtigste Strategie sind 200 Milliarden
Euro mit denen wir Gas und Strompreis
Bremse es möglich machen ich glaube das
ist naiv ist durch Sozialprogramme und
Sozialpolitik hier entgegenwirken zu
können vor allem dann nicht wenn wir
inmitten in diesem Kulturkampf stecken
indem man beispielsweise sich auf der
einen Seite für eine gendergerechte
Sprache einsetzt was richtig ist in
meinen Augen und auf der anderen Seite
sich bevormundet fühlt von einem
Mainstream der einen vorschreiben möchte
wie man sich zu äußern hat das sind über
Jahrzehnte gewachsene misstrauenswelten
Mister uns Gemeinschaften
die Spurensuche geht weiter von der
Geburtsstätte der AFD zu dem Ort wo sie
wachsen konnte wie nirgends sonst
Dorfchemnitz Erzgebirge hat keine Schule
und keine Kneipe mehr eine schwierige
Wirtschaftslage und ein Rekordwert bei
der Bundestagswahl jeder Zweite hat hier
AFD gewählt
hier gab es genügend Gründe wenn ich
dann früher denkt dass man ganz anderes
Leben im Ort und man hat kulturelle
Möglichkeiten was jetzt halt alles nicht
mehr so läuft wie man sich hätte gedacht
nach der Wende aber haben sie die Sorge
dass das noch weiter steigt mit der AFD
psychologisch
radikaler wird
so wir Rechtsextremismus
doch Chemnitz ist ja einer der
Hochburgen der CDU gewesen also ich habe
immer CDU gewählt
ja und dann gibt es dann eben es ist
vielleicht nicht der letzte
weisheitsschluss die AFD aber es ist für
uns auch irgendwo irgendwo eine Hoffnung
eine Hoffnung dass mal was anders wird
Hoffnung projiziert in eine Partei die
sich über die Jahre in Spitzenpersonal
und Auftritt radikalisiert hat aber
insbesondere in Ländern wie Thüringen
oder Sachsen längst eine feste Größe ist
aus der CDU-Basis Herausforderungen nach
einem Strategiewechsel im Umgang mit der
AFD es ist als meiner Sicht politisch
extrem unklug 30 bis 40 Prozent der
ländlichen Bevölkerung die Bevölkerung
ländlichen Raum zu sagen eure Stimme
zählt nichts mit denen die ihr gewählt
habt reden wir eine dabei gibt es aus
dem adenauerhaus eine glasklare Ansage
zur AFD alle liebäuggelei mit diesen
Leuten führt für uns nur ins Elend und
deswegen ist meine ganz klare Botschaft
wir machen da keine Zusammenarbeit es
gibt keine Übereinstimmung der
cdu-chefordert
Brandmauer ein Mauern fallen immer es
war auch Marie Antoinette die der
Meinung war um Form der französischen
Revolution weil sie gesagt bekommen die
Leute haben kein Brot zu essen dann soll
es halt Kuchen essen
das hat sie dann eingeholt und auch so
sieht man im Konrad adenauerhaus manches
bisschen an den Realitäten vorbei hat
der sächsische Ministerpräsident hat
diese Woche keine Zeit für ein
ZDF-Interview zum Umgang mit der AFD er
greift im Osten populäre Forderungen auf
auch gegen die Mehrheit in der eigenen
Bundespartei damit wir hier auch den
Preis selber im Griff haben und darauf
setzen dass man auch nach diesem
furchtbaren Krieg auch wieder zu
Lieferverträgen mit mit Russland kommt
Wurzen Nordsachsen hier hat der
Ministerpräsident mit diesem Kurs
durchaus Fans aber nicht unbedingt
Wähler
sympathischer Mann eigentlich ja er
versucht das Beste rauszuholen was raus
so und geht im Moment zeigt dir die AFD
ist die CDU für Sie noch eine Option
nein ich bin sich vertreten von den
Parteien im Moment
warum das fehlt überall geht arbeiten
und hat nicht die Spurensuche zeigt auch
das Erstarken der afd-bundesweit trifft
insbesondere auch die unions-